Molly the monkey likes to climb.
She climbs almost everything.
She loves to climb to the very top of things.
Molly climbs all day long.
She climbs a big, tall tree.
She goes to the top branch of the tree.
She likes to climb on monkey bars.
She climbs in and out of the bars.
She reaches the top of the monkey bars.
Molly climbs up a tall flagpole.
She goes all the way to the very top.
Molly likes to climb the tall tower.
Up and up and up she goes.
She climbs all the way to the top.
Molly climbs up the big ladder.
She climbs up the ladder to the roof.
Then she climbs the roof to the top of the house.
Molly likes to climb high mountains.
She climbs all the way to the top.
She likes climbing mountains most of all.
Molly likes being on top.
But Molly always has to come down.
Sometimes, coming down is more fun than being on top.
Sometimes it is not.